ja handy alarm ein gutes stichworte paul
karin prien die bildungsministerin von
schleswig holstein cdu die auch im
expertenteam von armin laschet war hat
wie unsere zuschauer und wie viele
andere politiker auch mitbekommen dass
wir diesen handy alarm haben und
schreibt auf twitter handy alarm ist die
traurige chiffre für die totengräber
jedweder
vertrauensvollen zusammenarbeit ein
anschlag auf unsere demokratie
ich halte diese aussage von einer
bildungsministerin in deutschland einer
bildungsministerin in schleswig holstein
für einen wirklichen skandal ein
anschlag auf die demokratie ist das
höchst zweifelhafte verständnis von
pressefreiheit was offenbar karin prien
hat das was wir machen ist aus sitzung
die am ende darüber entscheiden was hier
in deutschland passiert
aufzuklären zu informieren und unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer dorthin
mitzunehmen um zu zeigen was am ende aus
deutschland wir denn dort hinter diesen
verschlossenen türen wird darüber
entschieden was die cdu in
koalitionsverhandlungen macht das ist am
ende investigativer journalismus den wir
hier in der gesamten politik redaktion
bei bild betreiben und das karin prien
als bildungsministerin von einem
anschlag auf die demokratie spricht ist
ein echter skandal es ist ein beitrag
zur demokratie und keinen anschlag zur
demokratie ein anschlag auf unsere
demokratie also die bildungsministerin
hat sich dermaßen im ton vergriffen
schwer vorstellbar dass sie in dem
experten team von armin laschet war im
nachhinein
karin prien hat sich in den vergangenen
monaten gerade bei corona finde ich
einen wirklich guten namen gemacht hat
sich sehr kompetent geäußert so habe ich
sie wahrgenommen wird als politikerin
ich verstehe das ja dass man sich als
politikerin ärgert darüber dass wir
darüber informieren und natürlich
verstehe ich den wunsch von politikern
in geschützten räumen zu sprechen aber
die aber doch weil ein vers einen
anschlag zu nennen ist es eher eine
zumutung an uns demokratie was da gerade
passiert und es keine klarheit herrscht
und auch nicht absehbar ist das heißt
also von einem anschlag auf unsere
demokratie zu sprechen da fallen mir
ganz andere sachen ein die die man so
bezeichnen könnte und das ist wirklich
eine frechheit ist da absolut außerdem
gebe ich dir vollkommen recht denn man
darf eines nicht vergessen da geht es ja
nicht ausschließlich um cdu interne
themen die dort gerade im bundestag in
der fraktionssitzung besprochen werden
sondern unter anderem darum was künftige
koalition bedeuten in deutschland ob es
eine ampel doch noch geben könnte was
mit jamaika ist und die bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesem land unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer die haben
das recht dass unsere reporter sich so
hart einsetzen dafür dass sie das
herausfinden was dort gesprochen wird
und dass sie sich dann ein meinungsbild
bilden können von dem was dort
diskutiert was wir auch unter welchen
bedingungen eine solche koalition solche
absprachen zu stande kommen ob es komme
laien sind geschäfte das eine gegen das
andere du gibst mir dies und man trifft
sich auf dem kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenner oder ob es überzeugende
diskussionen sind es ist ein beitrag zur
demokratie absolut offenbar will karin
prien die bildungsministerin lieber
kleine kugel klingel runden in der union
wie sie es in der vergangenheit gegeben
hat wo man zusammensitzt und dann
darüber spricht wie man deutschland
verteilt wer welchen posten bekommt und
wo wir das noch hin schieben und solches
machen nein das wird es mit bild live
nicht geben wir schauen genau dorthin wo
diese dinge diskutiert werden und werden
unsere zuschauer auch weiter darüber
informieren auch wenn offenbar einige
cdu politiker das nicht wollen sie
wollen das verhindern dass eine
bildungsministerin von anschlag auf
demokratie spricht ist ein absoluter
skandal